THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
ON PALM SUNDAY, SOUTH BEND
MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG THREW
HIMSELF INTO THE PRESIDENTIAL
UNVEILING PARTY.
>> THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
TO TELL A DIFFERENT STORY THAN
"MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN."
THERE IS A BEING SOLD TO
INDUSTRIAL AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES, THE MYTH THAT WE
CAN STOP THE CLOCK AND TURN IT
BACK.
>> Laura: NEVER MIND TRUMP HAS
SPARKED A MANUFACTURING DRAMA
RENAISSANCE THAT'S BEEN UNSEEN
IN DECADES.
SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE, MORE THAN
450,000 MANUFACTURING JOBS HAVE
BEEN ADDED TO THIS ECONOMY.
BUT WHEN YOU'VE GOT FANCY
MAGAZINE COVERS AND MEDIA
ACOLYTES.
ALTHOUGH RIGHT MEDIA TYPES, HAVE
YOU NOTICED?
THEY ARE DEJECTED AFTER THE
RUSSIAN INCLUSION FLOP.
THEY FOUND THEMSELVES A
BRAND-NEW POLITICAL MESSIAH.
>> A REALLY SPECIAL DAY
YESTERDAY.
EVERYBODY STOPPED.
THEY WERE WATCHING TIGER, AND
THEY WATCHED MAYOR PETE.
I DON'T KNOW.
TEN YEARS FROM NOW, 20 YEARS
FROM NOW, IT JUST MIGHT BE A DAY
THAN A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK BACK
ON AND SEE HISTORY BEING MADE.
>> IT WAS A REMARKABLE DAY, TWO
REMARKABLE EVENTS.
YOU ARE RIGHT TO CALL THEM BOTH
REMARKABLE.
>> Laura: SCINTILLATING
ANALYSIS AS ALWAYS.
THEY ARE COMPARING TIGER WOODS,
ONE OF THE GREATEST ATHLETES OF
ALL TIME, WHO WINS THE MASTERS
AFTER AN 11 YEAR DROUGHT THAT
INCLUDED HUGE PERSONAL AND
PHYSICAL STRUGGLE, TO
MAYOR PETE, MAYOR OF A MIDSIZED
CITY WHO ANNOUNCED HE'S RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, TIGER IS AN ORIGINA
ORIGINAL.
BUTTIGIEG SOUNDS AWFULLY LIKE HE
IS CHANNELING THE LAST DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT.
>> I RECOGNIZE THE AUDACITY.
OF DOING THIS AS A MIDWESTERN
MILLENNIAL MAYOR.
>> I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
CERTAIN PRESUMPTION IN THIS,
CERTAIN AUDACITY.
>> WE LIVE IN IN A MOMENT THA
>> WE LIVE IN IN A MOMENT THT
COMPELS US EACH TO ACT.
CHANGE IS COMING, READY OR NOT.
>> WE ARE CHANGING HOPE --
CHOOSING HOPE OVER FEAR.
WE ARE CHOOSING UNITY OVER
DIVISION AND SOUNDING OF
POWERFUL MESSAGE THAT CHANGE IS
COMING TO AMERICA.
>> Laura: WELL, BENEATH THE
OBAMA CADENCE, PRETTY GOOD, BY
THE WAY, AND THE BOY SCOUT
DEMEANOR, MAYOR PETE'S RAP
DOESN'T QUITE ADD UP AT LEAST
NOT YET.
HERE'S THE FIRST PRINCIPLE OF
HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> FIRST COMES FREEDOM,
SOMETHING OUR CONSERVATIVE
FRIENDS AND COME TO THINK OF AS
THEIR OWN.
BUT LET ME TELL YOU FREEDOM DOES
NOT BELONG TO JUST ONE POLITICAL
PARTY.
>> Laura: THAT'S JUST SILLY
AND PATENTLY FALSE.
WHO SAID IT DID?
WHEN YOU HAVE LITTLE TO RUN ON
IN A RACE WITH 17 OTHER
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY CHALLENGERS,
IF IT SOUNDS GOOD, JUST SAY IT.
>> OUR CONSERVATIVE FRIENDS CARE
ABOUT FREEDOM BUT THEY ONLY MAKE
IT PART OF THE WAY.
AS IF GOVERNMENT WERE THE ONLY
THING I CAN MAKE SOMEBODY UNFRE
UNFREE.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
YOUR NEIGHBOR CAN MAKE YOU
UNFREE.
>> Laura: HE DIDN'T QUITE
EXPLAIN WHAT THAT MEANT.
HE WENT ONTO THE NEXT THING.
COULD YOUR NEIGHBOR TAKE AWAY
YOUR FREEDOM?
AND NEIGHBOR CAN DISAGREE WITH
YOU AND BEING ANNOYING AND EVEN
COMMIT A CRIME OR CIVIL
INFRACTION AGAINST YOU, BUT HOW
CAN A NEIGHBOR MAKE YOU UNFREE?
WE'LL FIND OUT MAYBE.
MAYOR PETE SEEMS TO SEE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A
CRUSADING FORCE FOR GOOD THAT
SHOULD BE USED TO PROTECT US
FROM OUR NEIGHBORS.
UNDERSTAND THIS.
THAT VIEW ITSELF IS PRETTY
RADICAL.
FEDERALIST 45, JAMES MATTIS AND
EXPLAINED THAT THE POWERS
DELEGATED BY THE PROPOSED
CONSTITUTION OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE FEW AND
DEFINED.
THOSE WHICH ARE TO REMAIN IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENTS ARE NUMEROUS
AND INDEFINITE.
THE SENTIMENT ABOUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD DO, THE POWER
SHOULD BE, WAS REPEATED BY
NUMEROUS STATE DELEGATIONS
DURING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RATIFICATION PROCESS, INCLUDING
BY NEW YORK.
THEY UNDERSTOOD THAT FREEDOM
CONTRACTS WITH AN EVER EXPANDING
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PRESENTS
BECAUSE IT MOVES INTO EVERY AREA
OF YOUR LIFE.
BUT AGAIN, FOR A SUPPOSEDLY
TRAILBLAZING CANDIDATE,
BUTTIGIEG IS JUST ANOTHER
CONVENTIONAL LIBERAL.
>> WOMEN'S EQUALITY IS FREEDOM.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT FREE IF
YOUR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CHOICES
ARE DICTATED BY MALE POLITICIANS
IN OFFICE.
>> Laura: OKAY, WELL, BUT
ABORTION IS FREEDOM?
CERTAINLY NOT TO THE UNBORN
CHILD OR FOR THAT MATTER THE
CHILD BORN AFTER A BOTCHED
ABORTION IN THIS NEW DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
I DON'T SEE THE FREEDOM THERE.
AGAIN, PUSH PAST THE CAREFULLY
STUDIED METICULOUSLY MEASURING
RHETORIC AND WHAT MAYOR PETE
REALLY HAS IS A BEEF WITH
OUR CONSTITUTION.
>> WE CAN'T SAY IT'S MUCH OF A
DEMOCRACY WON TWICE IN MY
LIFETIME THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
HAS OVERRULED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHY SHOULD OUR VOTE IN INDIANA
ONLY COUNT ONCE OR TWICE IN A
CENTURY?
OR YOU ARE VOTE IN WYOMING OR
NEW YORK.
>> Laura: OKAY, WELL, WE LIVE
IN A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
NOT A PURE DEMOCRACY.
MAYBE THEY LEFT OUT THAT ENTIRE
DISCUSSION FROM THE HARBOR
GOVERNMENT LECTURES.
BUT THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
PROTECTS THE VOTE OF PEOPLE IN
STATES LIKE INDIANA.
OTHERWISE BACK TO THE FRAMERS,
GOVERNMENT OF, BY, FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
NEW YORK.
BY THE WAY THIS REVOLUTIONARY
CANDIDATE IS BASICALLY A CARBON
COPY OF THE MOST RADICAL
HOUSE FRESHMEN ON THE ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE, ASKING ALL THE
SKEPTICS...
>> ARE YOU SAYING FOR INSTANCE
THAT SOME OF THE TALK ABOUT
RETROFITTING EVERY BUILDING IN
AMERICA OR TRYING TO MAKE THE
COUNTRY CARBON FREE BY 2030,
THAT THAT'S UNREALISTIC?
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
IT.
IF WE CAN'T DO CARBON FREE WILL
DO NEXT CARBON FREE.
WE ARE TAKING OUT AS MUCH AS WE
ARE PUTTING IN.
>> Laura: TRANSLATION: A
MASSIVE WEALTH CONFISCATION IS
NEEDED, FORCED AND OVERSEEN BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
FULFILL THIS GREEN NEW DEAL.
BY THE WAY, A GOVERNMENT WHO
UNDER PRESIDENT PETE WOULD
DECIDE WHICH CARS NEED TO BE
SENT TO THE TRASH HEAP AND WHICH
BUILDINGS ARE UP TO CODE.
MAYOR PETE IS ACADEMICALLY VERY
ACCOMPLISHED AND HE DESERVES
REAL RESPECT FOR SERVING IN THE
NAVAL RESERVES.
SEVEN MONTHS IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT HE IS A RUN-OF-THE-MILL
LIBERAL ON MOST ISSUES AND IS
RUNNING AGAINST AN ECONOMY THAT
IS ON FIRE BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHO IS LARGELY KEPT US OUT MORE
FOREIGN ENTANGLEMENTS THAN MOSTL
FOREIGN ENTANGLEMENTS THAN MOSTB
FOREIGN ENTANGLEMENTS THAN MOSTR
FOREIGN ENTANGLEMENTS THAN MOSTL
FOREIGN ENTANGLEMENTS THAN MOST.
IF THIS WERE MAYBE
GEORGE W. BUSH PRESENTING OVER A
CRATERING ECONOMY WITH AN
UNPOPULAR WAR ABROAD, MAY BE A
GUY LIKE BUTTIGIEG WOULD STAND A
STRONG CHANCE.
BUT GIVEN THE PROSPERITY AT HOME
AND AMERICA'S CURRENT PLACE IN